one of the most amazing things about the
parallel growth of data science and
genetics has been the growth of data
the human genome has about 40 000 genes
and that in turn is made up of about 3
million base pairs
the first human genome was sequenced in
2001 and took several years to complete
but in recent years researchers have
sequenced thousands of genome
and it's becoming relatively simple task
for a lab to do this nowadays
what this means is that genetic data is
now produced much faster than it can be
organized or analyzed or interpreted
or implemented part of this is that the
methods for structuring data
that is having a shared way of putting
it together and making it easy to
transport between labs and between
researchers
as well as methods of communicating the
findings lag dramatically behind the
development of the ability to get data
data is a good thing but you have to be
able to make sense of it
indeed we have a lot of data that is
potentially of great use
there's a lot of untapped potential
let's discuss about a few of the things
that had been
particularly successful in using
genetics and the data science of health
care
number one is predicting disease risks
through genetics
when most people think of genetics and
disease they think of single gene causes
like the gene for cancer
but things are rarely so simple most
diseases involve what are called
polygenic interactions
or the combined effect of many genes
possibly thousands all at once
the enormous increase in the amount of
data available along with the
development of data science have made it
possible to detect many of these
polygenic effects
so they can actually now say this
combination for instance
a 400 genes collectively work to predict
a particular disease
there's a unique study on parkinson's
disease conducted as part of the
parkinson's progression markers
initiative
that made it possible for researchers to
combine data from genetics
from imaging from clinical data and from
demographics data to altogether develop
a highly accurate model for predicting a
patient's risk of parkinson's disease
similarly researchers at other
institutions have also made progress on
mining dna data to predict diseases
ranging from coronary artery disease to
breast cancer to diabetes
and a host of others
but it's important to remember that dna
is not destiny
even in identical twins who share the
same dna
diseases do not show up the same really
what data science do is they give
probabilities
but not a concrete this is the way it is
and that's important to remember
because not only are there tests for
things like certain kinds of cancer or
parkinson's
but also researchers have been
developing tests for things like iq and
mental illness
some of which because they're based on
dna can be administered while the embryo
is still in the womb
and this raises a huge number of ethical
dilemmas
we'll talk about some of these later but
it recalls the movie gattaca where
people were categorized and really
channeled according to their genetic
potential
it's important to remember that in
something like identical twins
who again have 100 the same dna
things like schizophrenia major mental
illness only 50
concordance what that means is if one
twin has developed schizophrenia there's
only a 50
chance a flip of a coin that the other
one has it as well
so it's important to be a little humble
a little circumspect when interpreting
the probabilities that come from
predictive analytics for diseases
through dna
and there's also a need to focus on
controllable factors
especially when you look at things like
heart disease
there's so many things that a person can
do like diet and exercise
that can help reduce the person's risk
even if it never changes their dna
but keeping that all in mind the ability
to gather huge amounts of genetic data
and the mechanisms that are making it
easier to sort through potentially
trillions of data points
to try to find an association with the
disease are bringing exciting potential
for finding and diagnosing diseases and
understanding their nature through the
combination of genetics and data science
you